un bonjour le matin un bon soir le soir
et entre les deux tout un tas de tâches
dans nos résidences
le concierge ballet il distribuait le
courrier fut un temps il accueille les
visiteurs et rend tout un tas de
services
mais la situation de concierge ne fait
pas rêver bien des clichés accompagne
ses supposés pipelette indiscrètes et
médisantes mais plus que leur image ce
qui préoccupe les concierges c'est leur
salaire bas voire très bas 1748 avec son
nom c'est très difficile la profession à
son syndicat depuis 1960 mais n'a pas de
convention collective à l'époque
résultats des salaires très variable pas
bien élevé alors bien sûr ils sont
parfois loger ils reçoivent des étrennes
en bonus de la part des locataires mais
là encore combien est généreux le prix
d'honneur pour tenter de se faire
entendre les concerts je manifeste en
1978 et oui la conseillère n'était pas
dans l'escalier aujourd'hui mais dans la
rue vous dire que plus de 50 mille
d'entre elles gagnent moins de 700
francs par mois et qu'elle demande un
privilège qui ne se monnaie pas un petit
peu plus de considération
autre revendication en 1985
les concierges demandent à être payés au
smic le problème c'est que ce sont les
copropriétaires qui fixe leurs salaires
et ils ne considèrent pas leur présence
dans la loge à disposition des
locataires et visiteurs comme du temps
de travail effectif pendant cette garde
elles peuvent se livrer à d'autres
activités elles peuvent soit garder des
enfants dans la loge soit faire de la
couture
peu à peu le nombre de concierge a chuté
ils étaient 74 1152 en 1990 59000 en
2016 jon hamm
cette première cause dont les années 90
l'installation massive d'interphone pire
encore depuis 2000 seuls 10% des
habitations construites dispose d'une
loge pour concierge votre facteur
l'entretien des parties communes de plus
en plus de syndic s'adresse à des
entreprises de nettoyage
même si leurs rôles les plus limité que
celui de concierge s'aperçoit vite que
c'est par beaucoup moins cher et que sur
tous les entreprises ne s'occupe pas de
la petite vieille du cinquième étage
depuis 2009 une convention collective
encadre la profession le salaire minimum
est calée sur le smic avec des avantages
en nature tels que le logement comme
cela se pratique encore couramment
[Musique]